so this talk is all about abusing the
security assumptions we have made about
usb devices
a security analyst
posted at this section of the most
impressive device here
which is actually one of the smallest
ones so
logically i went around and started
shopping for all sorts of random things
the fanciest device is here in the intel
box
every time we open it it will play the
intel jingle
probably a horrible abuse of their
trademark since there is something truly
evil in there
um but we're trying to keep it a little
bit light since this is um fairly dark
talk
let's start with something much more
benign before we go all dark and deep
this is something that was on sale on
think geek i think it was a black friday
a few years back
there is a whole class of devices called
annoyatron
something you would lose in the cubicle
of someone you don't particularly like
and every once in a while would make a
chirping sound just to annoy them make a
squeak
no idea where the sound came from
this is the computer version of that
it is actually pretty nicely designed
not something you have to fiddle with to
configure
here
there are switches
it is a usb device of course
with the dial for time delay
you select the time delay and it will
flip your caps lock tap the keyboard or
move the mouse or all three
and this is perhaps
perhaps the most benign of these things
gareth mace
designed a smaller stealth usb caps
locker about 10 years ago
for an april fool's day
or you could build
an eight dollar
one with the digispark if you don't want
to fiddle with proto board yourselves
garrett's version may be less polished
but it fit almost completely in the usb
port
it uses an atmel avr 80 tiny 45 chip
and has great educational value
as you learn
how to run a usb stack right on the
hardware
there is no os here
carrying out this
attack is hideously simple
obviously you can do it without any
particular privileges
you just stick it in the back of the
computer of your victim and when they
log in it will have access
in some cases even without logging in
because it is a keyboard
an hid class device to be precise so it
is a keyboard and or a mouse
this one is innocent enough
but from there things get quickly worse
the hid class of the usb protocol
defines human interaction devices
keyboards mice game controllers and a
variety of other low bandwidth devices
like magstripe readers
which are really keyboards
these are all hid devices in the usb
world
thermometers
rfid readers
barcode scanners
even usb ups batteries
are interfaced as hid devices sometimes
at princeton they actually taught a
class about turning random hardware into
an hid device as their class project
you can find the lectures online
one benefit of a well-defined
specification like usb hid class is the
abundance of device drivers available in
modern operating systems
on the downside are the inherent trust
keyboards are
granted
and the possibility for usb devices to
change their type or announce additional
sub devices while plugged in
with usb's default behavior of accepting
any device that connects to it
if there is a driver for it
um
so let's start looking at how we can
exploit all this
the tomo is a very small device
also not meant to do anything evil
and it is basically the size of a ubi
key
you of course all know what a ubiki is
it's a second factor device that
basically fits inside a usb port
tomu is a usb platform to prototype
things like ub keys
the author explains that while a ubi key
costs around 50
a similar device can be built for two
dollars in parts
his intent here is to drive down the
coast
the cost
of second factor devices by an order of
magnitude
but you don't have to build a yubikey
substitute with a tomo
you have a micro controller
so you can build pretty much whatever
you want
the only thing is
what do you have
you have a cortex m0
so you are writing to bare metal you are
not writing to an os
eight k's of ram 64 k's of flash
oh
and it's the first open source hardware
association part certified in australia
it's available from seed studio
so you don't have to go and assemble
your own
and it has way more flash than a
digispark
64k instead of eight
you don't have a whole lot of software
or complex stacks here
but if what you're doing is usb and has
a two button
two led ui
you can basically build it here this
could potentially be a hidden device
fitting inside a usb port entirely
on the other hand there are much better
platforms for an attack
later we will see one with four cores
and eight gigs
but it is interesting to prototype this
kind of ubi key-like application
limited interaction
but you could probably build your
annoyatron with this platform
it also seems like completely
interaction-free devices are not as
interesting
or at least not as malevolent
i guess things are interesting only when
they cause trouble
so let's look at something that will
cause trouble
so i plugged in the annoyatron and have
access to your keyboard
either because the os trusts keyboards
inherently and lets them in
or because i leave that plugged in
and when you log in the device gets in
you usually need both to occur
again physical access is both necessary
and sufficient condition to pawn the
device
we have an entire industry of pen
testers
and the gold standard for them is a key
stroke injection tool disguised as a usb
drive
which is this
the rubber ducky
the usb rubber ducky is the original
keystroke injection attack tool 10 years
old
although the hardware has been updated
while it looks like a usb drive to us it
acts like a keyboard when talking to the
os
and typing over 1000 words per minute
specially crafted payloads written in a
custom scripting language mimic a
trusted human user while entering
keystrokes at superhuman speed
it is named this way because if it
cracks like a keyboard then it must be a
keyboard
you have the shell
you can just type your way to success
you don't need the crafted zero day
overflow
whatever
you just type on the shell
and from the keyboard
in windows you can always get a shell
with windows r in case you don't have
one
this is the full rubber ducky kit in its
current version first and third are
parts to assemble it into a standard usb
thumb drive case well standard a few
years ago now they look different
the second is meant to enable keystroke
injection into a micro usb device
effectively enable enabling hid attacks
on android smartphones
then we have a usb adapter to load
payloads into a microsd card
you put the sd card into this adapter
then load the attack script
and then put the sd card back into the
ducky
and then we have the core
rubber ducky device itself closing in on
the hardware
on the left is the micro sd card slot
that conveniently lets you swap a
library of pre-made payloads without
having to load them every time
the replay button
is in the center of the shot
this is convenient during development to
avoid having to remove and re-plug the
usb drive all the time
your fingers will thank you because the
edges of the board are pretty sharp
not nice to have to grab a pcb with your
fingers
but it's also good on the device so you
don't stress the soldier joint of the
connector
continuously until you break it
the use of the button can also be
redefined although the button itself is
not accessible from outside the case
finally the led up top
lets you know when the payload is
running green when it works red when an
issue is detected and again the led is
also concealed when the case is closed
on the flip side we have the atmel avr
cpu powering the device and some support
electronics
the pins on the left side should be a
jtag header
but i have never seen them used so i'm
not 100
sure
the specs
the system is avr powered
while it is not an arduino in practice
it resembles it in many ways
the internal flash and ram make board
bring up simpler
if you are an embedded developer you
know what i'm talking about
and the potentially unlimited mass
storage via the sd card interface make
it extremely flexible in the kind of
payloads it can carry
the led can flash in multiple colors
signaling execution state or error
during development
jtag and gpio access combined with the
standard atmel dfu bootloader make this
a potentially modable platform
but we haven't seen much hacking in
terms of of modifying the ducky itself
because it is not a particularly cheap
device
we usually
see clones being developed instead
so look it's a keyboard
this is how windows sees it anyway
this is how the usb thumb drive looks
like when you actually plug it in
not that anybody is looking
this is a windows 10 system at the
latest update update level
all that windows is going to do is warn
you that it is configuring an existing
driver
you may see an
overlay the first time
but it does not ask for permission
it does not ask for anything
and that one time warning
message
automatically dismisses itself
so by now we have all understood that we
have a rogue keyboard to do our bidding
but what can we do with it
there are three primary attack vectors
to be concerned with
the first is file exfiltration
that is copying files to a remote web
server
the ducky is a keyboard
you don't copy files to a keyboard
so the keyboard the ducky is instructing
a system to copy files to a remote drop
in some bad part of the internet
anonymizing the attacker
a second attack
in the windows environment exfiltrating
domain credentials and passwords is the
default target
even if encrypted
these are prized target
as the attacker can brute force them
off-site
and you can always get wi-fi passwords
while you're at it
these are already in the clear in
windows just ask them for them with the
net show command and windows will tell
you
a third attack vector is initiating a
reverse shell
and the ducky can start a reverse shell
in just three seconds beating any human
user at this task
all this stuff usually targets windows
i am not a windows guy so i had to build
a little dedicated setup here in my lab
with these acer 100 dollar machines that
could be infected with all the horrible
stuff we will see today
i have built automation to re-image to a
known clean state
it has taken me forever as i'm not a
windows wizard
i guess i learned something about
windows backups which may be useful
someday but the reality is that some of
these devices like the rubber ducky have
a company behind them there is a
reputation to defend
but others come from nameless sellers on
alibaba or ebay
some devices we will see are simply
scary
some are even known to phone home to
unknown remote servers for reasons that
so far were not determined
in any case
to show this we need to change os so
windows here
we come
where is the duckling
so i'm going to show you uh a payload
that i call setek astronomy
which is preloaded on my rubber ducky
looks like it's loading
and this is an example payload of
effectively just going to a web page you
insert the key
it just
fires off a browser and goes to
download a gif from my personal account
at red hat and
this is
something that those of you that are
familiar with the movie sneakers will
recognize
so
the first time you plug this in windows
10 will show a pop-up setting up hdci
device no confirmation or action is
required
the settec astronomy payload effectively
just
opens
a web page it doesn't start a browser it
tells windows
that it wants to open a web page and
my type resolution for windows does the
rest
it sees that
chrome is the default browser here so it
opens chrome and
and it loads it
so let's look at what the payload
actually is
here we'll see
the source code
so
ducky code is a scripting language for
keyboard input it includes pauses
modifiers
things like control or windows key
string input
it is all very simple but not in a naive
way it was designed to be easy to use
great ux
the delay instruction is important since
usb rubber ducky
has the capability to start injecting
keystrokes as soon as it receives power
from the bus
and while usb is capable of receiving
the keystroke frames the operating
system may not be ready to process them
and most likely it is not ready
um
the other aspect is that you're typing
blind
it is more akin to spear fishing
you have to make a reasonable guess as
to what is happening
on the other side
os and application wise
like
betting that they are running excel or
knowing that the target is windows
in this case
we are assuming windows 95 or newer
which seems like a pretty large fishing
pool
let's look at another payload
so um
we have uh the hello def con
it's another very minimal thing
so
this one will um
open a file and type some text into it
nothing
and nothing particularly complex here
but
we want to show how the process works so
you need to encode the ducky code into
um
into something that the interpreter on
the
ducky itself can run this inject.bin
file
and to compile that
you need
[Music]
an encoder
several encoders exist
i am partial to the online one because
it's convenient it should be duck
toolkit dot com
and what you do is that you load here
the code
that um
that we're looking at
so
like so
and then you just um
encode
encode the payload
and um
you download the file
there are other encoders um
that can be run locally i believe there
is one that's java based most of the
tool chain is available
large chunks of it are also open source
um
i don't like to rely on
outside tools while doing a presentation
so
i have the encoded file already here
how do you load this so
we have to remove
the sd card from the docking itself
put it in the device that makes the sd
card appear as a storage device not a
keyboard
load the inject bin
into the sd card
this is a drive so it behooves us to
eject it properly
and then
we put the sd card back
into the ducky
and
plug in the ducky
really it
most of the time of the code was spent
in waiting
waiting to make sure that the os was
ready to take
the text
here we're just scratching the surface
payloads can be optimized hardened
obfuscated
and the light library of payloads that
have already been written exists out
there this device is a community you do
not need to build payloads
there are collections
which is unfortunately ideal for script
kiddies
um
basically a thousand words a minute of
whatever nastiness you want to put it in
there
so
be nice
in an unprecedented feat of cinematic
accuracy the rubber ducky was apparently
featured in an episode of mr robot
who knew hollywood could get hacking
right even once
plug this guy in wait 15 seconds then
yank it okay
thanks to a tool called women cats it
will pull all the cash passwords and
domain info
it's a rubber duck
um
it's close enough
almost correct i'm not sure what
happened there but
seems good to me
these are backup slides showing the
hello payload in case windows decided
not to work so we're going to skip them
and then there is the rise of the clones
according to what i shall hereby call
the wally law of ecosystems
in an open system success will bring
what commercially are freeloaders
it is a good sign for a healthy business
and here it results in hardware clones
using the same or similar tool chains
the micro duck
is a stealthy hid injector
that can fit in the usb a port itself
while thomas's project is a three dollar
clone of a ducky
built using the digistump digispark
platform and a tool called duck 2 spark
this kind of development shows how
active and vibrant the rubber ducky
community is even after a decade
this is an incredibly popular tool
a more recent take on key injection was
released not long ago on crowd supply
commissioned by kevin mitnick for a
conference keynote and implemented by
olaf tan and dennis go
this is a redesigned ducky the payloads
in this case are written in arduino
bootloader access within the cable can
be triggered by a magnet
and the bluetooth remote endpoint is
also available
this is effectively indistinguishable
from a standard apple charging cable
but equally nefarious micro usb versions
are available
so what do we do to counter these
attacks
what we can do is something like this
and this is basic usb security this is a
device called sync stop
as a cio you can buy a bucket of these
order that everyone use them
don't worry they still won't
this is a device that cuts the data
lines of a usb connection preventing
data siphoning at charging stations
now known as the juice jacking attack
so if i'm charging anything at the
airport's usb charging stations
it goes through this
so i'm getting only power if i'm
plugging any of the rogue devices that
we're going through into my system to
charge it
it goes through this
so there is no data connection period
good luck hacking me through the voltage
i'm sure they'll figure that one out at
some point but they're not there yet at
least i hope
that seems like basic prophylaxis
it is not always practical however
because it is stopping devices providing
you power from adding data
but
uh while in a lot of cases we just want
power in equally large number of cases
we
need a data connection
this is a bus
not a not a battery charger
a more customizable approach could be
built with a device like the usb safe 2.
conceivably when you control the
firmware you could choose what behavior
to respond with you could decide to
filter on the class of the device
the hid the id of the device or some
other property like its serial number
the current device protects from
excessive voltage limits to preset
levels
and most interestingly
sets in software the data protection
mode
this means we can choose
where the data lines are connected or
blocked in
software which is why i'm saying this
could be interesting to build something
more complex on
and this is an interesting concept
but it would still take a serious amount
of effort
and
if value can be demonstrated maybe it's
possible
you would need to add the full usb stack
here
not a trivial exercise and the hardware
would
need revving up
since pretty much every time i speak
about this topic someone asks me what i
would do
well this is where i would start
so let's look at the device a little bit
more the usb safe is also interesting to
monitor what is actually going on in a
usb chain
as it has independent leds for data and
power lines
you can see them here at the usb a side
of the board
up top and on the bottom
the board is a two layer sandwich the
leds are in the bottom layer
the single button up top in the middle
of the picture controls both the current
level set and the data pass
pass-through or blocking behavior
one is a toggle while the other is a
press and hold and these modes are
conveniently stenciled on the back
by the way i don't think this will
protect your electronics from a
deliberate usb killer type of attack at
200 volts
but it will definitely help while
developing your own electronics as it
stops
over voltage up to 15 volts so
an accident would be stopped not a
deliberate attack
another company called capable robot has
announced a programmable usb hub that
has the ability to switch on and off
power and data lines from software
they meant it as a way to plug and
unplug misbehaving peripheral
peripherals on a robot
or for hardware testing
depending on actual software
implementation this may be closer to
what i was describing when it eventually
ships
of course
blocking by device id vendor id or
serial number can be bypassed by any
attacker privy to your security policy
and willing to craft an attack just for
you
so to stop that we need cryptographic
certificates
which in turn require managing authority
actually willing to revoke the chain of
trust of rogue players
this is a thorny problem with lots of
bad karma to be earned for the general
solution
but if you're trying to manage just your
local problem um you can essentially
have a white list of devices that are
allowed and block everything else
perhaps
um that's the most plausible approach at
this point
another device getting even fancier here
is called pyso
a similar thing but instead of being a
pass-through this is a usb storage
device
you have three buttons and a tiny oled
screen
basically it is a tiny linux computer
geared to providing more flexible
storage than a plain card would it is
built on a pi zero so it cannot provide
the usb on the go behavior of switching
between host and device but it is still
quite interesting
it comes with a kit of screws and you
can combine it with a pi zero to produce
a working computer
a super flash drive built on pi zero
it comes with a hardware kit to screw on
the pi
in some versions it's it include a 3d
printed cover to make it more robust for
everyday use
i have not found an application for this
yet at least not
an evil one
but here is an interesting idea a demo
application press button 1 provide the
arch linux iso
select option two now it's an ubuntu
boot iso
option three now it's fedora
it is cute conceptually it's like the
tomu we have seen earlier
but now we're higher up the stack we
have all of linux
not just the bare metal environment tomo
provided
and obviously it's more powerful and has
more storage
but it is the same button plus usb
interaction model supplemented by by a
tiny screen so it can talk back to you
at least a little bit
now let's go back to evil things where
we left the ducky
for pen testers the solution is to get
in
that's what they are paid for they have
a contract to do it
put a few plants on the right machines
and when some of you log in the morning
they're in
besides your machines are not patched
it's too easy it's like shooting fish in
a barrel but it gets worse
at some point someone realized that
different classes of usb devices have
different inherent permissions
for example a storage class device may
get different access from a network card
enter the bash bunny the grown-up
sibling of the rubber ducky
this one same vendor by the way
can do the undergo behavior we were
discussing just a minute ago but on
steroids this usb stick can show up as a
storage device and a minute later it is
a network card and then it can become a
keyboard
it keeps connecting and disconnecting to
change the driver it talks to as needed
because different driver classes have
different capabilities and different
implicit granted trust
what is absolutely amazing to me
is that in our industry where basically
no one can get ux right
basically you work for apple or your
product sucks
usability wise these security products
are amazing
they're actually really easy to use
i don't understand why they can get ux
right and no one else can but um this is
amazing to me
the specs on this hardware are also
absolutely impressive quad-core cpu half
a gig of ram eight gigabytes of storage
an interesting additional attack vector
enabled by the bash bunny is to show up
as a network device
plugin advertise a very fast route with
fantastic metrics
you can do this so that the right
network driver is already there in
windows
no need to get approval for a new driver
now you get the system to route all
network traffic on the machine into this
fake network that promises to be faster
than anything else out there
where you can inspect the network
traffic before forwarding it out through
the normal interface that actually is
connected somewhere
so it actually reaches its actual
destination
you are inspecting all of the machines
network traffic but no one monitoring
the corporate network ever
ever sees what you're doing because it
is happening on localhost
these are exploits that have already
been written for the bash bunny so you
do not even need to put in the effort to
code them
which is scary
you get in the network path as the
default route
then you're nice and you let them see
the internet but just so that
they don't notice you're there
a different take on the theme is the
cactus wh id
it includes a wi-fi access point so your
hid attack is no longer blind
we're looking for all intensive purposes
to a hardware remote shell
note the case it ships with
once locked closed it cannot be opened
without breaking it ships open for
inspection which is great for our
pictures
as you can see the wi-fi part of the
device is powered by the inevitable
esp8266
and to facilitate the process of
weaponizing usb gadgets you can wire
another usb device's pins to the pads on
the bottom left here
the new attack vector here is that
you get a usb powered knick-knack like a
plasma globe or a nerf gun turret
and wired data lines to this
pass through the power from the host
device you're parasitizing
so that there is also power
and then the attacker will mail this as
a present to the target
now you have a plasma globe with a big
company name on it
it is basically a social media exploit
without the social
you just mail it to them
so beware unexpected devices in the mail
they are the new hardware enabled spear
phishing
this already sounds bad enough but fear
not it gets worse
and now this one is actually rather
outrageous and it is making me lose
faith in the concept of computer
security as a whole to be honest
why bother hacking you with the device
if i can hack you with a cable
from the picture it looks like it is a
big cable but it is actually a rather
tiny cable
and yeah it has something at its end
this something is actually a gsm phone
it gets power from the usb connection so
this is potentially a phone with an
infinite battery
the device itself is marketed as a
location tracker usable in cars
where a thief would not be able to
identify the usb cable as a location
tracking device
this is utter nonsense the device has
poor tracking precision you would never
find the stolen car
and makes no mention of tracking in its
packaging
so is it a device to protect your car
no it's a high-speed data and charging
cable it says so right there
i also want to highlight how the
packaging is also designed to be opened
and closed without trace
not something you usually see
this is because you need to add a sim
card to the cable to make it active
in this manner the cable can be
delivered to the target still in its
packaging
it gets worse then i say it would it
does
you can buy this monstrosity for 9.85 on
ebay
free shipping of course
are we worried yet
okay let's all take a deep breath
what in the heck is going on here
this is not only evil it is also cheap
you would think that if you use this to
spy on someone at least in the united
states
you would go to jail for unauthorized
wiretapping
but the device is effectively just a
phone in a ridiculous form factor so
it's probably legal for amazon and
alibaba to sell it
corey doctorow calls it trickle-down
surveillance
because this is apparently a low-quality
low-cost copy of a device the nsa had on
their leaked tailored operations catalog
code named cottonmouth
the cable itself looks like this
a ribbon usb cable
with a usb a connector on one end and
the micro usb on the other
some folks
have pictured it next to an amazon
basics charging cable and the size of
the connector is frankly not that
strange
you can come here to my office to see
the cable and judge for yourselves if
you want
in the meantime trust me it does not
stand out much
until
until it is fielded for use and the
casing is super glued shut as one does
the cover slides off to reveal a small
board this is a gsm listening and
location device hidden inside the plug
of a standard usb data charging cable
supports the 850 900 1800 and 1900 mhz
gsm frequencies it's quad band phone
the cover of the usb a slides off
so you can add a micro sim card in the
slot
the end cap of the usb a plug
locks in place so that folks do not find
out accidentally there is a phone in the
cable you have given them
it can do a bunch of things it can track
the location of the cable
it does not have gps so it won't give
you too precise a location
we're looking at tower triangulation
with a service like skyhook wireless
or the carrier's advertising data
facility
i'd say we're looking at roughly a mile
plus or minus in precision with a more
densely populated area likely delivering
better resolution
it has a microphone it can listen to
what you're saying
it has a collection of at commands so
that you can configure it
it can send text messages
to tell you where the cable is
you can text to the cable to change its
mode of operation
and it even has a decibel trigger mode
it can call you when it hears a sound
over 40 decibels so you can listen to
what's going on
the chip is a mediatek cpu that does not
have a published spec sheet
it is believed to be a chip designed for
low-cost smart watches
there is a civilian port that shows the
initial bootloader sequence but once it
goes past the bootloader it is no longer
configured the kernel does not post
messages there
this device has undocumented commands
that nobody knows what they do
and sends packets to china
in places that we do not exactly
understand but presume are used for the
geolocation service
never
ever plug this device into any computer
unless it is a secured lab facility
here is the view inside the case
at best as we can tell usb lines bypass
the device itself and go back to the
cable
save of course for stealing a little bit
of power off the wire
the mini sim card reader is in the
center
this device is quite finicky about the
sim cards it will accept
on the right you can see the electric
microphone commonly found in any
standard usb charging cable
not
on the flip side we find the pads to the
serial port conveniently labeled
the mediatek cpu is in the center stage
the device is actually rather hard to
demo
because of
the decommissioning
of gsm
networks in the united states
this is a problem i've run into
several times
since i started researching this four
years ago initially att still had a g2
network but
that is long gone
i thought i could get around it using
t-mobile but despite multiple attempts i
could not recently get the device to
join their network
it is somewhat hard to debug as it is a
headless unit and
the
um
the serial does not output anything past
the bootloader
first i thought it was the limited
antenna and low transmission power but
going outdoors did not help
i tried checking for a sim pin but that
was not the problem either
so here is what you would have seen
the cable is in use meaning it is
powered it should not matter if a
battery or a wall power source is in use
we can now do multiple things
the coolest of these is making a phone
call to the cable
the hacker over there knows the phone
number of the cable and she dials it
on this side the cable picks up the call
and starts sending back what the
microphone can hear until we hang up
not bad eh
but this hacker is a trendy one and she
texts the implant next
after the hacker sends the three letter
command loc in a text message to the
same number she will get a text message
back geolocating the phone to a city in
the world
westford massachusetts
and including a link to a page on a site
called gpsui.net
showing a map of the approximate
position with roughly one mile accuracy
another interesting text message is one
one one one four times one
this activates a mode in which the
implant will call the attacker back if
the noise at the location exceeds 40
decibels
perhaps a conversation is underway
a security analyst named mitch dissected
the implant three years ago and
published a long report
lots more details in his right app
so in closing
don't
obviously doing any of this is in
violation of u.s laws requiring two
parties to be aware a call is going on
or both parties having to consent to
conversation being recorded and probably
a bunch of other things
please don't do anything like this it is
a crime in most u.s states
clearly we have rules about this not
being acceptable behavior but what is
changing is that folks willing to break
the law can do so with a very low
barrier to entry
namely 25 on amazon or ebay
before you had to go to some black
market purveyor of illicit goods and to
find out who they are in the first place
drive up to some strange place in new
jersey and purchase some bugs from
backside of tony sopranos
restaurant
now you can go on alibaba and have them
express delivered to you
i'm not impressed this is not what the
future should be like
so let's go back to the security aspect
we were joking about the fact that it
was easy to break in but realistically
this is
physical access
if we have a device like we can do
things to it
we can also do it over wi-fi okay
that hardly matters what matters is that
this brings the last usb key attack to a
new level
in a military base people are trained to
shoot on site when they see a usb key
but in a company setting people are much
more relaxed
i'm amazed this sort of thing exists and
is being produced on any scale
i paid almost nothing for this device
something to be on the lookout for if
you work in any sort of operational
capacity in a security sensitive
industry but it's so cheap that
where is the barrier where is the limit
where is the
effort
so let's put it in economic terms or in
mba terms let's dump it down a little
things change when you drop the cost of
something by a factor of 10.
think of the raspberry pi we went from
300 computers
to 30 dollar computers
and then the pi zero
showed
to
the right kind of thinking
and did another almost 10x drop
to five dollars
this cable is dropping the cost of data
exfiltration or surveillance or covert
activity
industrial espionage to the point where
everyone can afford it
i'm not going to say we do not have
bigger problems but this is not nice
cheaper industrial espionage is not the
positive column
it's not in the positive column of the
progress ledger
this is why any place that has any kind
of real security should be pouring glue
in their usb ports
there is just no way
to offer a reasonable solution you can
put locks in the usb ports and attackers
will find a way to break those or your
employees will circumvent them for the
attacker out of convenience
the only real solution to make usb safe
is not to use it
barring that you need to work
to limit the blast radius of a breach
the only reason why usb security is not
a bigger issue today is that we're so
bad at network security that it is
easier and cheaper to exploit you
remotely that is not what i would call a
comforting thought
and maybe really there is no hope
but i choose to remain an optimist
a reminder use a sync stop or any
trusted brand of these or a device that
you could inspect yourself
and here is a little story this is the
reconstruction of a tweet that was
posted at scale 16 in pasadena
someone ran to their session
in such a hurry that they forgot a
charger on the main hall
you know the hallway track where we all
say hi
the conference twitter lit up with folks
thinking this was a honeypot
so perhaps there is hope after all
on that dot that is what i have
this ends the usb hacking 101. i hope
some usb hackers better than me are in
the audience and you can teach me new
tricks in the live chat session point
out
devices i left out
ideas thoughts
bring them on
we can make this um
talk even better in the next edition
here is my contact info you can find me
on twitter send me email
if you see this recording later and come
up with ideas or questions please send
them to me
remember that speakers are pavlovian
devices so if you like the talk please
let us